les troupes sont été récemment chassés
de ce village ukrainien
mais leur passage a laissé des traces
une équipe chargée de compiler des
preuves a été dépêché sur place
aujourd'hui nous avons inspecté les
sous-sols
[Musique]
poignages des personnes ont été
torturées on sait désormais qui sont ces
soi-disant policiers dans cette
soi-disant police populaire des mesures
pour les traduire en justice seront
prises dans les prochains jours
d'ophtalmologue
âgé de 40 ans cette ukrainien a été
arrêté le 22 mars dernier par deux
soldats russes
longuement torturé il a accepté de
témoigner à condition que son nom et sa
voix soit modifiée
je me tenais ici comme ça c'est là
qu'ils ont commencé à me donner des
coups de pied un peu partout
[Musique]
des hurlements
ignorés par les Russes mais aussi par
les habitants du quartier
effrayés à l'idée d'intervenir